depuis le début c'est l'hymne quand vous
répondez aux questions vous dit monique
et michel vous les appeler par leur
prénom
vous dites pas mon père ou ma mère est
ce que c'est parce que vous n'arrivez
pas à le dire vous ne voulez pas le dire
vous ne pouvez plus le dire est ce que
ce sont des étrangers pour vous
aujourd'hui que vous appeler par leur
prénom parce que vous ne vous
reconnaissez pas dans cette histoire et
vous êtes tellement loin de tout ça que
pour vous c'est monique et michel est
plus mon père et ma mère
comment vous expliquez que vous voulez
prénome y ait sans les intitulés comme
vos parents ou quoi chez les mx
aujourd'hui en maison d'arrêt saisissons
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas considéré comme
leur fils sinon ils ont fait ces choses
c'est qu'ils respectent pas la famille
s'il avait du respect pour moi de
l'amour polaris
il n'aurait pas fait ça donc à partir de
là pourquoi je devrais considéré comme
pour moi ils sont morts
et vous voulez dire que en plus d'être
des criminels ils nous ont trahis en
quelque sorte mais au moins jouer un
rôle pour moi c'était papa maman aux
attaquants s'en sort dont
et bien ensemble c'était bien et après
j'ai appris qu'il mentait qui joue un
jeu ils ont été jusqu'à se servir de
selim comme appât pour piéger dernière
aussi aujourd'hui où les considérait
plus comme vos parents et vous voyez le
reste de la famille les oncles les
tantes fait les frères et soeurs de
leurs frères seraient sous les voyous
qua non enfin celles qui ont coupé le
contact
parce que je suis le fils 2 mais non
personne mais mais vous avez un
demi-frère de les citer tout à l'heure
et et une soeur aussi c'est ça oui mais
demi-frère demi soeur j'ai pas encore
d'accord est tout ce qui est honteux
tantes cousins cousines et que michel
fourniret avait de l'humour oui
apparemment oui
ah oui on n'avait qu'un navet c'était
quelqu'un de normal était autoritaire il
discute avec beaucoup de monde à
sart-custinne tous les voisins détester
mais c'était quelqu'un de normal